how many times have you heard anyone say
let's meet for a drink at Penn Station
right it just doesn't happen because no
one wants to be there the first thing
that you do is you build a larger
network of parks I mean you know
Gramercy Park and Washington Square Park
these are teeny little pocket parks if I
were the master planner in 1750 let's
just say I don't know if I would have
done a single Central Park I might have
thought of it as two parks like an East
Side Park in a West Side park I mean you
had manufacturing on the edges and then
living and working in the middle we have
a great subway system a lot of ways but
the big problem with them is they were
developed privately by independent
companies and so you had some companies
that built Express lines for instance
but we're one of the few leaders that is
actually probably the only major city in
the world that has Express trains which
is an amazing thing but it's not spread
in a way that it's even and what that
does is it creates very very expensive
places where those Subway's go and very
inaccessible places where those Subway's
don't I think there are two major things
that the subway system is we needed a
way to get from the lower west side to
the upper east side I also think there
needs to be more crosstown connections
it's how do you make this sort of more
of an even grid and again the way sort
of London's Metro is or Paris as much
over especially Tokyo's which is an
extraordinarily robust citywide system I
would get rid of all privately owned
cars I mean why is there free parking on
the streets for private automobiles you
know which land is dedicated to cars and
trucks let's just start with your
typical New York City
2/3 of it is filled with people parking
their cars that they use only a couple
times a week we just got rid of free
parking on the streets you immediately
increase the capacity of the city by 40%
all of a sudden you can imagine these
incredible greenways with bikes and
parks
New York City's biggest mistake was the
demolition of Penn Station not just
because we lost a beautiful beautiful
train station it really in my mind was
the beginning of our disinvestment in
infrastructure and the only way to solve
the problem is to move what the New York
Times called the manhole cover of
Madison Square Garden off of the station
build a new arena nearby somewhere
beautiful new arena and bring light and
air back to the station I mean it was
designed for one hundred two hundred
twenty thousand twenty thousand people a
day and it gets over six hundred
thousand a day think about that when it
comes to investment and building and
infrastructure it's a city of Kent and a
city that's falling behind generally our
transportation systems are substandard I
think we're now just getting around the
idea of ferries and bicycles and other
modes of transportation that can
actually move us around more easily I
mean the fact that we have not built a
single bridge in this city
years is an embarrassment if we don't
straighten this out we are going to fall
behind I think what the city still does
right is that we're still this city of
opportunity we are still a place where
you know a CEO from a company and a
custodian from a company take the same
subway to work every day it's always
been a city of inclusiveness you're
constantly running into each other that
kind of friction is really the sort of
beauty of the city it's constantly
inspiring